the jurgen experience it's uh it's a
strange
time when it comes to the the reality of
the differences between genders
it's a very strange time because it
doesn't it doesn't
like no one's ever said like men are
better than women or women are better
than men we're just different things
and transgender people are different as
well it's all we're all just different
we should be accepting of each other and
loving of each other and give each other
equal rights and laws and
and respect but when it comes to
athletics there's a reason why men don't
compete against women
and i had this bizarre conversation with
this guy once
who uh has this tv show where he kind of
debunks things but when
i got him alone to talk about these
things like without a team of writers
when you
you leave someone to just their opinions
and he had these sort of very
progressive talking points that he would
kind of blurt out
but then when i started challenging him
on these and
going deep he realized he didn't even
really think about this
he just wanted to appear that he was
progressive which i am
i am a progressive person i know i look
like a meathead but i'm very progressive
yeah i just look at reality though i
grew up
with martial arts and with fighting and
i know there's a [ __ ]
radical difference between males and
females it's radical
it's not it's not small it's not subtle
it's radical you mean in physical
strength
physical strength and violence and
psychology
and attitude and in competitiveness
it's radical there's a radical
difference
and also there's a spectrum and some
people
are far more feminine than they are
masculine and they happen to have
penises
and some women are far more masculine
than their feminine they have to have
vaginas
but it doesn't change the norm it
doesn't change and it certainly doesn't
change in the on the high ends of these
spectrums
you look at the high spectrum ultra
female versus ultra male
you're looking at two radically
different things yeah
yeah and i like really like what you
said
about i i'm getting emotional again
um i like what you said about
just accepting and understanding each
other yes
that to me you don't have to accept
bad behavior you don't have to accept
hurtful behavior
but it does help us to really work hard
to understand it
so and those are the extremes of
behavior um
but you're right we're different and i
think it's interesting and it's exciting
the way that we're
different the ways that we're different
and testosterone really does help to
explain
so many of those differences so
understanding that hormone
helps us understand each other and i
want it it helped me
even though i have been teaching about
this stuff for ages writing the book and
especially
reading about the transgender
experiences help me
to have sort of this epiphany so you can
see how emotional
i am right i'm like ultra emotional
my husband is a british philosopher
and he is not uh he doesn't get angry
he doesn't uh really express a lot
a huge range of emotion he's a wonderful
guy and i
love him but i've always kind of picked
on him
and thought there was something wrong
with him for not
being more emotional not being able to
have these long conversations about
emotions and psychology and
what happened in his childhood to make
him like that and
i have a temper he doesn't have a temper
i
cry during lecture and can't even and
cry at home and you know can barely
control that
my epiphany was i'm not better than he
is because i'm so in touch with my
emotions i have
issues like he probably has issues too
but
he doesn't have to come to be closer to
me in my way of being in the world
i need to work on accepting who he is
he's an awesome guy
and i was always trying to get him to be
more like me and i think women
really want men if they're in
heterosexual
relationships to be more like them
emotionally but i had this epiphany like
no it's working out and our marriage
would be better if i just
shut up about some of the getting him to
be more emotional all the time
i need to take the gifts that he's
giving me and i have to look at myself
and where my emotionality which i'm you
know getting emotional again um
but that was all through learning about
like learning more about this hormone
and what it does
it's just who he is as a man it's not
that all men are that way
but it did help me just the
understanding helps us to
accept each other and that's sort of one
larger point
in the book that i don't try to make so
explicitly but i hope that
um and again i don't mean we have to
accept bad behavior
but we can try to understand these
extremes of male behavior that are
disturbing and more disturbing than
extremes of female behavior
you know i can cry and have a fit but
i'm not
raping anybody um well because that's an
extreme
that's a bad extreme of male behavior
that we need to understand but let's
understand like where that's coming from
instead of shutting down the
conversation
or shaming men for just being men who
are all men are being blamed for the
extremes of male behavior
they that's ridiculous in my view
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience